Hello, my name is David Haas.
And as you can see from the title,
the subject is going to be cryo-cooling protein crystals
and other macromolecular crystals.
The reason that crystals are cryo-cooled
is so that they reduce radiation damage
during synchrotron X-ray detection.
I did this work on cryo-cooling
the very first protein crystal back in 1967.
And then I left science in 1970
and didn't discover that, in fact,
it was being used until just a few years ago.
It turns out that the message
that I'm going to deliver today
is in fact that research that you publish
-- your scientific research --
in peer-reviewed journals will in fact...
could possibly be used years and years ahead,
when you can't even foresee what will happen,
and that's exactly what happened to me.
The article I published in 1970
was read
and has been used very successfully today
by thousands of scientists around the world,
with all types of synchrotron radiation.
So, I'm going to tell you the story.
And in fact, this is a picture taken of me
when I worked in crystallography for five years,
between 1965 and 1970.
And then I joined industry.
So, this is when I was a graduate student
collecting data at the University of Buffalo.
In 1965 I went on my first postoc,
and it was with David Phillips at the Royal Institution in London
And in fact you can see here the Lysozyme molecule.
He had just solved the structure in 1965.
And when I arrived he had suggested a project for me, and that
I look at trying to reduce radiation damage in protein crystals.
So I worked on that for a year and a half
at the Royal Institution with David Phillips, and of course,
at that time, Sir Lawrence Bragg was actually the director,
so he was very interested in the subject also.
A year and a half, I had no results whatsoever.
And then I left the Royal Institution
and went to the Weizmann Institute soon after that,
and I'll tell you that story later on.
But the important fact is that three dimensional structures
of protein crystals had become very important, and its actually
created any entire new field called structural biology.
In 1971, the Protein Data Bank was begun.
And this is a picture of the various proteins.
There were 9 protein structures solved in 1973.
The Protein Data Bank has basically
become the heart of molecular biology.
It is the resource where all the structures
of macromolecules are saved.
And today, there are more than 150,000 structures
that have been deposited,
both of proteins, nucleic acids, DNA,
and a number of other macromolecules.
One of the most remarkable things is that
each year, now,
about 10,000 new structures are being deposited.
That's about 50 a day.
And the data is being collected...
the crystal data for X-rays
is being collected on synchrotrons.
So, I only discovered this just a few years ago.
And when I went to my scientific meeting in 19...
in 2015, I was given a copy of this magazine,
which is a special issue of Journal of Molecular Biology --
50 years of Protein Structure.
And Max Perutz and, of course, John Kendrew
were the two scientists who determined
the very first protein structures.
But today, it is 60 years -- 2019 --
since the first protein structures were solved,
and it's been 52 years
since the first cryo-cooling of protein crystals.
The Protein Data Bank has increased
in the number of structures dramatically.
And what is surprising is that
about 90% of all these structures
in the Protein Data Bank
have been cryo-cooled,
meaning that the data was collected
at about 100 Kelvin.
From the Journal of Molecular Biology issue,
there was a paragraph that said the three most significant things
for the creation of the structural biology field
are in fact the invention of the synchrotron;
the cryo-cooling of crystals,
which permits them to be used;
and of course the high-speed computers
and the remarkable computer programs and software
that have been developed to solve the structures.
And just to amplify on that a little bit,
this is the synchrotron at Brookhaven National Laboratory.
There are 50 synchrotrons similar to this
around the world,
and they are available to all scientists.
A synchrotron produces X-rays
about 10 million times more intense
than the vacuum tubes that I used.
I mean... 10 million times... just remarkable.
You can collect the data on a single crystal
in a matter of minutes,
whereas in the 1960s,
it would take months or years to collect the data.
And of course, the synchrotrons...
now that they provide such an intense X-ray source,
the crystals are protected by cryo-cooling,
and simply...
putting the crystals into liquid nitrogen.
And that's exactly the way it was done in 1967.
That I'm going to tell you about.
And the third thing, of course,
is the magnificent computer software and hardware
that is available today
that permits three dimensional structures
not only to be solved
but also the graphic interfaces
that permit you to visualize them.
But there is also a fourth area.
And that is in fact the cloning to be able to produce proteins,
the purification of proteins,
and a third area, which is the crystallization of proteins,
which has become an entire field in itself,
just the ability to be able to crystallize
these enormous macromolecules.
So, this really is a Back-to-the-Future story.
This is the story that happened to me,
and that's what I want to relate to you.
As young scientists or graduate students,
basically,
you should realize that once you publish your scientific results
in a peer-reviewed journal,
it could be used anytime in the future.
And this Back-to-the-Future story
that I'm telling you
is exactly what happened to me.
50 years later,
I discovered that the work that I did...
which I had totally forgotten about...
I discovered it was very valuable.
So, in 1970,
Michael Rossman and I published the paper,
the second paper on cryo-cooling.
And the purpose in it
was taking on lactate dehydrogenase crystal,
cryo-cooled,
and we showed that, in fact,
the radiation damage at room temperature
is much more severe than it is at cryo-cooled.
In fact, we showed that there's
an improvement of ten times the life of the crystal
at low temperatures.
Today, in synchrotrons,
typically they consider the crystals
to have 70 times or more the lifetime
in the X-ray beam.
So, this is the first quantitative proof,
and it came out of this 1970 paper.
So, let me just review with you,
basically, my five years in crystallography
and basic science.
After graduating from University of Buffalo with David Harker,
we arranged for a postdoc
at the Royal Institution of Great Britain.
David Phillips had just finished working
on the lysozyme structure.
And in fact, Sir Lawrence Bragg
was the director.
After working a year and a half
on not having any results whatsoever
on reducing the radiation damage,
I went to the Weizmann Institute
because he (David Phillips)
had taken a position at Oxford.
And upon arriving at the Weizmann,
I decided that I'd already cont...
I brought all my supplies with me,
and I continued to work on the radiation damage,
probably...
on the project for about three more months.
In March of 1967,
I decided that it was absolutely hopeless.
I needed to find some other alternative.
And what I did, in fact,
was made a list of all the alternatives
that I could think of,
and I chatted with Wolfie Traub,
who was the director of the crystallography lab.
And I concluded that cryo-cooling
looked like the most promising.
And as fate would have it,
Wolfie Traub had just built
a cryo-cooling apparatus about five years before,
and it was sitting in the laboratory unused.
So... and not only that,
he said I could use it,
as well as the technician who was currently in the lab,
who was the one who built it,
and he would teach me how to use it.
So, I was able to cryo-cool lysozome crystals
with cryoprotectants.
They gave pristine diffraction patterns
like this one.
And then, in fact, after leaving it in the beam day after day after day,
there was no change.
And this was the first indication that I had
that in fact there was some protection,
or there was real radiation reduction,
in this lysozyme crystal.
So, this paper was published
from the Weizmann.
And then the Six-Day War occurred
in June of 1967.
I had already arranged with Michael Rossmann
at Purdue University
to go there, and I arrived in late 1967 at Purdue.
My project that I wanted to work on with Michael
was to show quantitatively
that in fact radiation reduction is performed.
And I was able to convince Michael,
by showing him those wonderful precession pictures
from the Weizmann,
that in fact I could do the project.
So, he loaned his diffractometer,
and I built this equipment at Purdue in 1967,
and we collected all the data during the summer of 1968.
After that, we wrote the paper.
And this was published in April of 1969,
as the Haas and Rossmann paper.
We submitted it in July of '68.
And basically, the most important part of that paper
was in fact this drawing
of the radiation decay,
which clearly shows
a ten-fold improvement in radiation reduction damage
in a cryo-cooled state.
Soon after that,
I had given a number of [talks] on this result
and the cryo-cooling of protein crystals
at a number of scientific meetings,
and basically, at each of the meetings,
there were no questions
and a number of people said it's nice work
but it has absolutely no application.
So, besides having a little depression from that,
I also decided I really wasn't fit for academia,
and I joined industry.
So, in 1970 through basically 2015,
I was out of the academic world.
In 2015, as I said,
I went to the American Crystallographic Association meeting,
and I started learning about structural biology,
I was invited to attend
the X-ray methods course at Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory.
And that was 2017.
16 days of intense study.
But the most remarkable part
was that in the first week,
we grew lysozyme crystals,
we cryo-cooled them,
and then we sent him to the Brookhaven synchrotron
and collected all the data
in a matter of minutes.
I can tell you,
one of my surprises was walking into the hutch...
the X-ray hutch at the synchrotron,
which is what this photograph is...
basically, the instrumentation looked so fantastic,
and I didn't recognize any of it,
except for the dewar,
the liquid nitrogen dewar,
which basically was the same dewar
that James Dewar had invented back in 1892.
So, I didn't feel so bad about that.
One of the remarkable coincidences
is that in 1892,
James Dewar did his work in exactly the same...
at the Royal Institution,
but it was also in exactly the same laboratory
that I did my X-ray work
when I was there in 1965.
And I'm sure James Dewar
would be very impressed about how his invention
is being used today.
So, the results of structural biology
and the Protein Data Bank
basically produced an entire foundation
for molecular biology.
And I'm sure many of you
who are in the biological sciences
have come to appreciate the value
of having these remarkable three-dimensional structures
and data available.
So, in my second presentation,
I'm gonna tell you about how my postdoctoral work,
50 years later,
has contributed substantially to structure-based drug design,
which has led to many of the drugs
that have been used for the HIV epidemic,
and as I will specifically show you,
the Lazarus effect,
which is one of...
one of the phenomena that happened in 1996
during the HIV epidemic.
I'd also like to thank the people
who helped me over the years:
as you might gather, David Phillips,
who suggested the original project
of reducing radiation damage;
Wolfie Traub... if he had not had, in his laboratory,
the cryo-cooling equipment that I used,
it probably never would have gotten done...
probably 10, 20, 30 years later;
Michael Rossman, I think who recognized
the importance of having a single crystal
that showed reduced radiation damage
so you could collect all your data;
and then I especially want to thank
Elspeth Garman,
who was one of the experts in radiation damage
and has taught me, in a matter of months,
what I did not learn in 50 years.
So, the final sentence should be
"science for the benefit of humanity,"
which is exactly what I see structural biology
has contributed.
Thank you.